here in the u.s tens of millions of
americans celebrated the fourth of july
in full force with concerns about the
pandemic easing nationwide
president biden hosted a fireworks party
for first responders and the military
with a reminder to keep up the fight
against covet
nancy cordes is at the white house nancy
what did the president say last night
good morning
good morning jerica well he said that
the country has gained the upper hand
against the virus that americans can
live their lives again and kids can go
back to school
but he also warned about the emergence
of new variants
and he said the most patriotic thing
americans can do
is get vaccinated america
is coming back together
at his largest gathering since taking
office president biden argued the
country
is closer than ever to declaring
independence from covid19
and think about how far we've come but
with the celebration a note of caution
that's not to say the battle against
cover 19 is over
happy fourth of july the white house
hosted about 1 000 people last night on
the south lawn
all of them were tested for covid
beforehand
but the delta variant is a growing
problem we're certainly seeing
the delta variant rise in our state
which is concerning
even as the pace of vaccination slows
our goal by july 4th is to have 70
percent
of adult americans at least one shot the
president
set that goal in may but fell just short
of it yesterday
as of this weekend about 67 percent of
american adults have had at least
one shot on saturday the president
visited traverse city michigan
and vice president harris stopped in las
vegas nevada
to encourage more americans to get
vaccinated
the white house has launched surge teams
to parts of the country
with higher rates of vaccine hesitancy
we have a lot more work to do
the white house did face questions about
the optics of holding such a
large gathering for the fourth of july
at a time when officials here say
they're still on a wartime footing with
this virus
really shows the tension gale between
the desire to celebrate the progress the
country has made
while being realistic about the
challenges that lie ahead i know
it is a balance that we need to figure
out thank you very much nancy